foreign
briefing for Thursday February 23rd I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
this week the U.S Supreme Court heard
two cases that could change how the
internet works in the first Gonzalez V
Google the family of a victim of an Isis
terrorist attack in Paris is arguing
YouTube which is owned by Google should
be held liable because it recommended
Isis videos to users
in the second Twitter V tomne the family
of a victim of another ISIS attack in
Istanbul is seeking compensation from
social media platforms on the grounds
that the platforms aided and abetted
terrorism at the heart of both is a
provision known as section 230 of the
communications decency act the law from
1996 Shields tech companies from
liability for what users publish on
their platforms and as some listeners
will remember it's been the subject of
debate for the last few years joining us
with more on the arguments the
implications and how the justices are
reacting is wsj reporter Jan Wolfe hian
thanks for being here hi there are two
cases here before The Supreme Court can
you tell us why they haven't been
combined so yeah there's two cases that
are very similar in one case it's
relatives of someone who died in a
nicest attack in France and then in the
other it's relatives of someone who died
in the United this attack in Istanbul
but the cases are very similar raise you
know similar legal issues we don't know
exactly why the court didn't hold the
arguments on the same day combined but
it's probably because as these cases
worked up through the lower courts they
were decided on separate grounds the one
argued on Tuesday Gonzalez versus Google
more directly tease up section 230 this
really important internet law that a lot
of people want to revisit that's because
the lower court dismissed the case based
on Section 230 but the case argued on
Wednesday Twitter versus tomne the
outcome wasn't determined by section 230
the lower court just said there wasn't
sufficient allegations to make out a
case that Twitter and other platforms
had aided terrorism so it was just
dismissed the more conventional grounds
and so I think that's the main
difference in the cases and probably why
they weren't argued together but okay
let's talk a bit more about the
arguments that are being made given that
section 230 is meant to Shield companies
from liability how are the families
making cases that the platforms here
should be held accountable section 230
generally Shields platforms from
liability over what users are doing but
you know it's not Ironclad once you're
Crossing into a threshold of being a
publisher of your own material then
you'd obviously don't get the protection
and what's at stake here is really
algorithms and where they fall into
section 230 analysis at least the way
the case was presented on the briefs it
offered up this interesting question
that some of the justices maybe seem
sympathetic to that algorithmic
recommendations like you get on YouTube
or at that point YouTube making a
recommendation to the viewer and not
just sort of being a conduit for what
other people are posting and so that
section 230 should not apply how are the
companies responding well I do think the
companies make a couple very important
factual points that are not in dispute
one is for instance that these terrorist
attacks in which the plaintiff's family
members died were not planned on the
platforms you know with the Istanbul
attack it's not like that was being
planned and coordinated over Twitter the
argument is that generally these
platforms allowed Isis to flourish and
that therefore they should be liable for
these specific attacks so I think one
thing you've seen is the lawyers for the
tech companies kind of bringing up this
idea of well are we really aiding and
abetting anything no we don't think we
are we were just offering the same
services that we make available to
everybody and if you say that we're
aiding Terror you can think of other
types of organizations Charities media
companies who might then be found to
have done the same thing and it's a
dangerous slippery slope okay but the
opinions that really matter are those
from the justices I just want to play a
few clips from the proceedings in
Gonzalez V Google the justices compared
the situation to you know a Bookseller
they compared it to a telephone company
and actually here's Justice Clarence
Thomas making the comparison to holding
a phone company liable for say
connecting somebody to the head of
Islamic State I mean if you call
information and ask for Abu dhabi's uh
number and they give it to you I don't
see how that's aiding and abetting and I
don't understand how a neutral
suggestion about something that you've
expressed an interest in is aiding and
abetting I just don't I don't understand
it and I'm trying to get you to explain
to us how something that is standard on
YouTube for virtually anything that you
have an interest in suddenly amounts to
aiding and abetting because you're in
the Isis category what does that tell us
about how the justices understand the
situation and do those comparisons help
them I think that a really common thing
for justice is to do particularly at
oral argument is talk about
hypotheticals because it helps them with
line drawing you know how can we create
some brightline rules that lower courts
can apply going forward so we saw a lot
of that here and I think the internet
law stuff really lends itself to that
where you have justices making these
hypotheticals to non-digital
environments because it just helps them
get their head around it Justice Kagan
got some jokes when she said look look
around we're not the nine great experts
on the internet here so I think there
was a lot of that I think the oral
arguments were a bit of a slog at times
according to a lot of people who are
commenting in real time because it is
just really difficult sometimes to do
this kind of line drawing and to also
create rules that are good Tech policy
ultimately that's congress's job and the
court is very aware of that that that's
one reason I think they want to tread
carefully they're interpreting section
230 they don't want to get in the way of
Congress making new laws that reign in
section 230 that's congress's job right
I actually want to play another clip
from Kagan this is a statute that was
written at a different time when the
internet was completely different but
the problem that the statute is trying
to address is you're being held
responsible for what is another person's
defamatory remark now in my example
you're not being held responsible for
another person's defamatory remark
you're being held responsible for your
choice in broadcasting that defamatory
remark to millions and millions of
people who wouldn't have seen it
otherwise through this Pro defamatory
algorithm and the question is you know
should 230 really be taken to go that
far is the is a sign that justices are
maybe leaning towards addressing 230 at
all maybe saying you know this shouldn't
go quite as far as some of the platforms
have allowed it to so my sense is that
there was a lot of concern or optimism
depending on who you ask that this would
be the case where the justices limit 230
which some people say is long overdue I
don't think that's going to be the case
now based on the oral argument it's
always really hard to read the tea
leaves and interpret oral argument but
the consensus among people who have some
expertise who watch this was that the
court just doesn't see this as a good
vehicle for revisiting section 230 this
case really tdub algorithms and whether
recommended content is platforms making
their own sorts of publishing that you
know is not what section 230 is about
but I think as the justices delved more
into it they just didn't see any bright
lines here what does that mean for big
tech companies will that just maintain
the status quo these companion cases
really had the potential to reshape the
internet fundamentally and they still do
because we don't know how the Court's
going to rule it's going to take some
months before we get a decision but just
based on the oral argument and the
comments we heard from the justices this
case is probably not going to be the one
that upsets the status quo the court
tends to release the real Blockbuster
decisions at the very end of the term so
you know my guess would be like late
June is probably when we're going to get
a ruling but it could come earlier
alright that was our reporter Jan wolf
thanks for joining us Yan yeah you bet
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsg .com
I'm Zoe Thomas from the
Widow thanks for listening
[Music]